this is a ridiculous
question i sometimes ask myself when i'm
alone what is the meaning of life
do you think about the big existential
kind of
why the hell we're here it's a cosmic
kind of joke kind of in a weird way
right i mean
joe said it the other day on maybe it
was you
saying that like he was just like you
know by the time you figure out what it
is you're out of here
you know it's kind of interesting or you
even start to figure out what it is
you're out of here it's like it's like
that's kind of funny it's like you don't
get enough time
to truly i think the meaning of life is
just like
at the end of the day do you feel it was
time well spent
was it time well spent that's
that's really what it is if you look
back do you go hey
it was time well spent like a pretty
good ride it was pretty good ride i did
i did it did a lot
i did a lot of things i i doing what you
say
is a part of it i think if you say
you're going to do something maybe doing
it
uh that seems to be extrapolating the
meaning of life questions
like you know what did you come here to
do i think it goes down
deep like who are you and what do you
want and you know what are you suited to
do and what
it does seem that like the people who
are most enlightened
that i've ever met or read books by
they ultimately land on humor like they
don't take [ __ ] seriously
they embrace the absurdity of it all and
just kind of
laugh at laugh at it in this kind of
simple way so it does seem that humor
is like one of the fundamental truths of
the scene
yes we're in and somehow it's love
humor humor can be love right people
laughing that that
sound is kind of like carolyn knapp who
wrote a book called drinking a love
story which is a
really good book about not drinking
drinking and then not drinking and um
she said the land you could understand
things as love that you i think one of
the last lines in the thing is like
people talking about their experiences
in life that that could be love like you
know laughter is love like i feel like
love and and finding it wherever you can
find it is
why we're here that's that connection
and laughter can be love and
you know figuring out you know something
that makes life better for a lot of
people can be loved
you know whether it's a vaccine or a a
technological advancement or whatever
like
you know all of those things i think can
be that feeling and i think that's
what's
important it connects you to a larger
frequency
you know i don't think there's a better
way to end it tim i hope
you're one of the voices i truly believe
that your legacy would be one of the
most important voices
of our time because you're fearless and
challenging all the absurdity
of uh the nonsense that of our
social and political discourse i hope
you keep doing it
i'm a fan i'm still a bit star struck so
oh stop it listen
i i your job i thought it was your
intellectual capacity
enjoying anything i do only underscores
how truly [ __ ] we are
but thank you very much yeah
thank you for talking today thank you
brother
you